last week I reported to you that Donald
Trump on Twitter announced a ban on all
transgender military service members
Donald Trump taking to Twitter and
saying that quote after consultation
with my generals and military experts
please be advised that the United States
government will not accept or allow
transgender individuals to serve in any
capacity in the US military our military
must be focused on decisive and
overwhelming victory and cannot be
burdened with the tremendous medical
costs and disruption that transgender in
the military would entail thank you
questions we had at the time the
depending on expect this another
question what is the exact policy and
how do you enforce the policy with
regard to existing trans servicemembers
we aren't going to be able to find a lot
of those things out for a little while
because in addition to learning that the
Department of Defense and Pentagon
didn't expect this announcement to begin
with Donald Trump also didn't actually
direct anyone at the Pentagon to do
anything so Trump has announced this on
Twitter Trump announces lots of major
direction and policy on Twitter but
tweets aren't actual policy guidance
we've sort of established that yes
Trump's tweets are declarations of
trumps position their declarations of
intentions but the people that work for
Trump don't take orders via Twitter so
the Joint Chiefs have since said when
they were asked reasonable questions
like oh how do you enforce this they
said oh no modifications to the
transgender policy are being made
because Donald Trump has sent public
tweets but none of us have actually been
directed to do anything and we've since
heard from the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs Pat that until Trump sends what's
called official directive to the
Pentagon nothing's going to happen if
you look at that announcement there you
see that it's in three tweets and the
first two were about ten minutes apart
from each other yeah and so a lot of
people at the Pentagon were at pins on
pins and needles wondering what he was
going to do if it was going to be
something major like war with North
Korea you can you imagine can you
imagine you have you have officials who
are just watching Twitter to figure out
are we about to bomb someone or are we
about to put boots on the ground
we're or are we about to honorably or
dishonorably start discharging thousands
of people based on their statuses
transgender individuals it's it's
whacked - the study was consulting with
his generals I mean that sounds like a
very big announcement which this was yet
it's just much different than you'd
expect White House was asked about this
they said well Donald Trump has every
intention of carrying this out so still
no answers - really serious questions
like how do you determine which people
already in the military are transgender
right what do you do if they're
discharged do you do it honorably or
dishonorably disorderly of course would
strip them of access to a lot of really
important veterans benefits that would
be a disaster even if you discharge
existing transgender military
servicemembers honorably after figuring
out who they are it can still be a
problem back under Don't Ask Don't Tell
you could be honorably discharged for
being discovered to be homosexual and it
would show quote homosexual admission or
homosexual conduct on your honorable
discharge which could present some
pretty serious issues when you're trying
to get another job you could be
hypothetically honorably discharged for
quote transgender admission and that
would still be potentially really bad
for you if you're trying to get a job
later on oh this would be horrible
especially if he does decide to
dishonorably discharged them because
then it's hard to get employment right
when you're talking about a group of
people who is already stigmatized and
has relatively high suicide rates I mean
this could get much worse it's an
absolute disaster it's an absolute
disaster so if there's a silver lining
it's that this has not actually been
policy that Trump has formerly directed
to the Pentagon yet but presumably at
some point that will change
assuming we believe Sarah Huckabee
Sanders and why would anyone ever doubt
something that Sarah Huckabee Sanders
says today's episode of the David Pakman
show is made possible in part by policy
genius life insurance can be confusing
it can be time-consuming but there is
one company policy genius that's making
it a lot easier policy genius.com is the
place to go to learn about life
insurance compare quotes from America's
top providers and save up to 40
percent on your policy they've got a
simple user-friendly website which helps
you figure out exactly which policy is
actually right for you and once you
figured that out policy genius will help
you find the best price if you end up
with questions they have a team of
licensed experts waiting to talk you
through it no call waiting no pressing a
ton of buttons to direct your call you
get actual customer service from policy
genius and they don't just do life
insurance you can also look at health
insurance options pet insurance even
protecting your income whatever you need
if you've been putting off life
insurance or just want to make sure that
the insurance you already have is right
for you check out policy genius.com
today where you can save up to 40% just
by comparing policies the quotes are
free no sales pressure zero hassle
policy genius.com